cbs news has confirmed that the
president
has been asking about a big real estate
deal
president trump has on multiple
occasions brought up the idea of buying
green land from the danish government so
michael how serious do you think
this idea might be it's quite serious
actually donald trump
trying to purchase what is basically a
semi-autonomous region
from denmark and now the government of
greenland issues this response saying
hey
we're not for sale saying it's not for
sale
is the classic opening gambit and is the
elder statesman of late night
what if i negotiated the deal i have as
much if not more negotiating experience
as trump
i mean come on an 11 o'clock time slot
on tbs
you don't just get that ladies and
gentlemen
tonight i'm going to get some advice on
buying greenland
from a top real estate team i actually
went over to greenland this morning just
to take a look
and here's what i would suggest i would
knock out this glacier just to get a
more open bicep plan and add a kitchen
island
definitely you'll do a fire pit in the
back with lots of seating
and if you want maybe knock this
mountain out of here so you have more
natural light coming in from the north
side
and to complete the deal i realized i
had to travel to greenland
myself i'm going to travel to greenland
as part of conan
without borders
but before i went to greenland i had to
google
greenland greenland is a huge territory
three times larger than texas and eighty
percent of it
is covered in ice year-round vikings and
inuit cultures have called it home
and since 1814 it's been a territory of
the danish
now that i was an expert the only thing
left to do was pack my chapstick
and head north and north
and north
[Music]
[Applause]
hello how are you
everyone just calm down how are you
i'm here to buy your country hi
here to buy your country hello i'm here
to buy your country oh hello
hello i'm here to buy your country i'd
also like that scarf oh yeah
you can throw that in on the deal here
to buy your country
i'm afraid about them no you don't think
it's going to happen it's going to
happen
we'll have a few drinks what do you like
to drink well
milk milk oh
just leaving the airport this is uh vivi
yeah dvd you want to just look this way
really quickly
don't crash there's vb vv is uh
oh sorry i made you look at the camera
and then we were almost
we're almost killed that would have been
my fault
look at that there's an iceberg right
there that's crazy it's fantastic
there's a little blue shed you guys have
it all
do you have a golf
i course we were driving into a quarry
this is the
nook golf club president trump
this is where you'll be playing golf
once the purchase goes through
are you excited about becoming part of
the united states
would you like you not you don't want to
be part of the united states no what's
wrong with us we're a great country
but you're all fat what's that
we're all fat do i look fat to you
grab grab that grab that what do you
think
that's a lot of fat that is so rude
that's a terrible misconception about
americans let me clear that up right now
only 90 of americans are fat
what an incredible landscape how long
have you lived here bv i have lived here
all my life but i'm from south korea i'm
not from
yeah i know you can have sort of a
southern greenland accent
this is our hotel tell me about this
hotel is it a good one
it's the only one oh it's the only one
what a great yelp review it's the only
one
it's the hotel how are you
very nice uh i would like to uh get a
room please
and i would also like to purchase your
country
from our prime minister well you tell
your prime minister that conan o'brien's
here
and he'd like a room and he'd like to
purchase
greenland i have eight thousand danish
crooners
well that's what you need it's too short
who are you to say you're not the prime
minister
you can't even buy an iphone you can't
buy an iphone for eight thousand kroners
well maybe an iphone fight
let's put this on the white house credit
card
and just bring that through okay
are we good yeah
this is easier than i thought are you
excited about becoming part of the
united states
not really pretty great country good
music in the old days
in the old days we still have great
music what are you talking about
what do you mean america doesn't have
good music anymore what music are you
talking about
50s 60s and 70s 50s 60s and 70s do you
think we haven't had good music since
then
what are you talking about oh eddie's
too michael jackson
all right so you like michael jackson
you like okay
this guy's not up on the news
excuse me are you excited about becoming
part of the united states
of america nope why not what's wrong
with our country
we've got really good fast food in
america that's great
fast food what's that it's not healthy
not healthy you guys are eating whale
blubber
you know i'll tell you something as an
american citizen you'll be able to eat
other american citizens
get all the flavor you want
welcome to america no welcome to
greenland
welcome to america i said america
oh i love this guy so tell me vivi
uh this is downtown nuke this is
downtown yeah the capitol of
milan yes are you willing to become part
of america
uh no not really why not you don't love
our country
[Music]
it's too fun for me well once we
buy you we won't seem foreign to you
anymore
do you like the fast and furious movies
do you like vin diesel no
me neither they don't make any sense how
can you solve crimes just driving cars
it makes no sense i'm with you on that
one
my name is conan here in uh greenland
children live inside
advertising
and then you stop okay let's cross kids
let's come across this is what americans
do
we bring order to a chaotic system come
on drew
hold on one sec
is there anything that you like about it
we put the cheese in the crust of the
pizza that was
us we came up with that have you had
that i don't like cheese
you don't like cheese well maybe you're
not part of this negotiation though
america no i said america
you're not going to believe this but the
best pizza i've ever had in my life
was not here
[Applause]
thank you you have a uh make america
great again yes
are you you're a big trump supporter no
but i would like to thank him for
all the publicity he's given greenland
oh so you're wearing this hat
ironically if you're
any part of america that you really like
what's your name
[Music]
oh
that's too many vowels you've used
you've used every vowel twice
okay and what is your name oh my god
can you say it again
since you're just making up names my
name is conan
do you know that uh president trump is
trying to buy greenland did you know
that
no yeah do you like that idea not
really what if greenland bought america
would you like that
you like that idea i'm killing with
these kids you guys are the best
do you want to come to los angeles and
be in my audience and just laugh at
everything i say
do you want to do that i will pay you in
just anything i say
kavanaugh
[Music]
[Applause]
our president donald trump wants to buy
greenland well i don't want trump to be
my president so
okay well he won't be president forever
he's only going to do three or four
terms max
and then uh he'll be done probably by
late 2048
probably by then we'll get uh joe biden
yeah he'll be like 120 by then yeah yeah
it'll be a brain in a jar
i really want to make this happen yeah
wouldn't you love it if i was your talk
show host
yeah that would be lovely so that's a
reason to do it don't you think
all right yeah let's just do it anyways
then yeah oh hey good
well you changed i'm optimistic okay
good yes think of it that way i will be
your talk show host so let's make this
happen thank you
i've been holding onto your shoulder for
a little while yeah no is that okay
did you notice yeah i'm just a big fan
okay but you noticed didn't you you
didn't notice didn't you
it's weird it's too long and it's still
too long
it's awkward in any country
[Applause]